en cette saison des amours les
batraciens rejoignent leurs points de
natal pour se reproduire
seulement à gombe et l'étang de la
bruyère est séparée de la forêt par une
nouvelle
alors depuis 12 ans nicole s'occupe
d'eux à l'aide des lycéens du chef de
tremblay sur mauldre et d'autres
bénévoles elles disposent des barrières
de 140 mètres de long financé par la
commune de gan b et le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
afin d'empêcher les batraciens de se
faire écraser
il arrive effectivement de la forêt ils
vont longer la bassée à un moment ils
vont tomber dans le faux et chaque matin
qu'au mois d'avril des bénévoles
viennent ramasser les batraciens des
sceaux pour les faire traverser en toute
sécurité
si nicolas commencer seule avec son mari
et son fils au fil des années d'autres
amoureux de la nature l'ont rejointe
comme aymeric il s'est arrêté il allait
la boulangerie de rappel et il a dit
loeb à l'année prochaine vous me
contacter je viendrai vous aider voilà
c'est aulas été contactée alors de alors
je note rahman chaque batraciens et
répertoriés pour prouver l'efficacité de
la démarche
il y à 12 ans 500 animaux ont été sauvés
cette année les 6 ramasseurs espère
dépasser les 2500 127 crapauds mâles
dix neuf femelles et trois triton palmé
ce qu'il fait 149 batraciens sauvé
aujourd'hui fort de leur réussite les
bénévoles ont demandé un système plus
pérenne de bâtera co d'uc soit des
tunnels sous la route dédiée donc le pnr
tout à fait d'accord c'est que ça fait
un an comme un conte a déposé le dossier
contacté le pnr se dit sensible à la
démarche mais le terrain est en complexe
des études hydrographique doivent être
menées elles auront lieu courant mars